foreign
zoo is with us in San Francisco hi Zoo
how are you
hey Mr Clancy how are you great how can
we help
oh that's so great to hear I am calling
because I'm so tired of living the life
that I'm living and I need your help
so the reason that I'm calling is
because I need to know or we need to
know my husband and I need to know how
to get my husband on board with the plan
and care about our home finances hmm
yeah
um we got married back in April of 2020
and my husband said that he had income
to bring to a marriage he come to find
out he had no money at all to come into
the marriage not even for the honeymoon
so he wasn't working our marriage
um or no savings
but no savings okay
he made a mistake or he lied to you
keep straight up wise completely wow to
the tune of how much
um he said oh I have enough money for
like six months of expenses
um he was moving from Michigan to
California at that time and it was a
flattering day
it flat out completely yes what else has
he lied about
spending
um he has borrowed so much money from
family members and
so we have our finances together now but
it's just not it doesn't seem to be
working well because you don't trust him
I I trust him yes I mean why give like
why do I trust him because he's my
husband no that no
you don't trust I mean I have a dog I
had a dog one time that would bite you
and he's my dog but he would bite you
I didn't trust him yeah even though he's
my dog
this dog bites oh my gosh
so what are y'all doing what are y'all
doing to build your relationship after
it started on lies
so we go to church and we've been
getting counseling at church and every
time we meet like we meet quarterly and
she's like yeah I'm going to change but
Dave it had he has not changed one bit
it's only getting worse and we've been
trying to start your plan since the
beginning of the year you don't need it
for you don't need a startup plan hey
what's he spending money on uh you said
that he's he's spending money he's not
telling you about it what's he spending
that money on he's spending money on
GoPros Electronics camera
he's 27.
so she married a child yeah
that's what kids do they do things they
know they're not supposed to do and then
when Mommy says what'd you do they lie
about it
and then Mommy says okay you're in
timeout and they they say okay I thought
about what I did and then they go back
and do the same thing again
that's exactly we got it to the point
that's exactly what's going on I'm sorry
that's frustrating I I can't get him on
our plan our plan is for grown-ups
so he's going you guys have to continue
and engage in in-depth counseling for
your marriage you guys you're in a mess
honey I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry because this this guy does
not want to engage anything that
requires self-discipline self-control
um maturity the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good
um he is about him he's not about you
he's not about your marriage he's not
about your future he's about him I can't
help someone in that situation I'd love
to but the best way I can help him is to
be mean enough to him that he goes and
does something good for himself
and starts starts to grow up because you
know a man
not a 27 year old male but a man
does not put his personal desires and
purchases in a lie ahead of the good of
the family and the good of his wife
and that's what you're facing right yeah
I'm so sorry me too I'm sorry yeah I
wish I wish I could I mean if I thought
I could take you guys if you guys were
both ready to go but you the work you
all need to the time you need to be
spending is not on Financial Peace
University it you need to be spending
time in the marriage counselor's office
and
and you know and if he won't go your
marriage counselor needs to help you
decide in your church setting what is at
what point is this marriage done
because I can promise you it's done if
he doesn't change I don't know whether
it's a decade
or whether it's 10 days
or 10 months but it's uh but but I've
worked doing what I'm doing and and I
know that I don't believe in divorce I
don't I'm not telling you to get a
divorce I'm not doing any of that but
I've worked with couples long enough to
know the lady in your situation will
hold her breath for some period of time
and when the when the volcano finally
goes off there's no putting the lava
back in I know that's right it's over
the switch is flipped and we be done and
no amount of spiritual shaming or
anything else will undo that I know
that's right so uh please please please
the two of you for the good of your
future for the good of each other spend
time on uh getting in a good solid
winning relationship where you're
serving each other not being selfish
being selfless and that's you know the
an immature and all of these things are
so it's so hard so hard wow I'm so sorry
so guys um disclosing a hundred percent
in truth of who you are about money and
exactly what the dollars and cents are
how much is in savings how much is in
retirement how much you make
um really early in the dating process is
uh is a valid thing because Jesus said
your treasure is where your heart is so
how you handle money and where the money
goes speaks about who you are as a
person it's a description of your value
it is and your values rather and so uh
young ladies demand that of these young
males to see if they're men young men
demand that of these young females to
see if they're grown women instead of
little princesses
is you don't you don't want to you don't
want this guys it's not fun it's not fun
oh so sad